Trickling water might seem harmless, even peaceful,
but in the polar regions sound is a sinister
warning of an event that could swallow up the Arctic landscape.
What would happen to the climate?
Why couldn't you eat fish anymore?
And how much carbon is stored in the Arctic?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if the Arctic turned into a mega slump,
we've really done it. Now we ignored all the warnings.
We ignored science. We thought we had more time,
but now the permafrost in the Arctic is melting at an abrupt
thought, which means it's happening fast.
As it melts this formerly frozen layer of [inaudible] plant
debris will release a massive amount of carbon into the atmosphere.
And now, because of all that carbon, our time is yup.
Covers an area about twice the size of the United States.
It's created when Tundra plants like grasses and mosses die
instead of decaying and releasing organic carbon,
the plant matter is frozen into a layer of soil trapping,
the carbon dioxide and methane that would have been released.
If this important layer in the Arctic disintegrates,
it would be catastrophic
as permafrost melts the ice buried beneath the soil also melts
the draining water carries heat, spreading the dangerous stuff.
Tunnel and air pockets are created.
And the ground sinks into the newly empty caverns below Meltwater
and rain fill the dents, expanding them into lakes.
If hundreds of these happened at the same time they could merge.
This would create one giant mega slump where the Arctic landscape
used to be.
The more than 13 million people who live in the Arctic would have to flee
immediately 1500 billion,
tons of carbon would be released into the atmosphere.
That's three times the amount stored in the plant it's forest.
This is bad enough, but unfortunately,
we're now in a positive climate loop.
Ice only increases the amount of heat. The earth surface absorbs,
which then melts more ice.
And this warms the planet.
Since the industrial revolution, humans have been releasing increasing Oh,
it's of carbon into the atmosphere and the positive feed back loop amplifies
that effect as the ice melts,
the sea levels will rise, wiping out whole coastal cities.
And even if you don't live in the Arctic or on the coast,
you'd still have a lot to worry about climate change would come fast and
fiercely droughts would dry up someplace as well.
Others would face an increase in precipitation.
Storms would rip through the cities that are left
mercury from the melted permafrost would enter the oceans wetlands and food
systems
wouldn't be able to eat fish anymore because they would have such high levels of
this dangerous chemical
and the Arctic mega slump would never stop growing
more and more of the Earth's ground would become unstable
four people to flee South to higher ground.
According to the 2018 Arctic report card,
the Spanish flu smallpox and the plague could still be held in
permafrost layers with the permafrost melted.
These diseases would be released and would spread rapidly among
densely packs cities. Like I said, in the beginning,
if the permafrost melts our time is up
in reality, mega slumps don't form overnight,
but while you might not wake up to one new giant mega slump,
they are happening.
The largest slump is in Barrigada in Siberia.
It's known as the gateway to the underworld.
It measures it's more than 900 meters wide and it's continuing to
expand.
And since the Arctic's temperatures have increased twice as fast as the global
average, these slumps are more likely to happen. Yeah.
Can we do to stop more mega slumps from?
Well,
our best option is to limit the amount of greenhouse gas released into the
atmosphere while capturing carbon dioxide.
If we fail to do this,
then we'd better find a way to rephrase the Arctic before it's too late.
That's a story for another.